trump has come out and stated this
problem
explicitly he was asked uh recently on
fox and friends about black lives matter
and he said without pulling any punches
black lives matter is a marxist
organization nobody's done for the black
community
african-american community what i've
done
and i will tell you they had black lives
matter
where did it start marching down streets
screaming
pigs in a blanket fry them like bacon
they were talking about policemen
policemen and women pigs in a blanket
fry them like bacon
so all of a sudden this has taken on
this air of
uh great respectability well
how does it start there it's a marxist
group
it's a marxist group that is not looking
for good things for our country and now
i see these leagues all kneeling down
and again nobody has done more for the
black community by
far i always say nobody other than i'll
give the one exception
abraham lincoln okay but even that i
mean to be honest with you but
nobody has done more than i have
but when i see people kneeling during
the playing and disrespecting our flag
and disrespecting our national anthem
what i do personally is turn off the
game
i love this this caveat okay maybe i'm
the best president for black people
maybe other than abraham lincoln
although frankly even him i don't know
okay moving on
and so i love that i mean obviously this
is entertaining stuff he's calling into
a top-rated morning show
people are listening to this but
crucially what he's doing here he's not
just
throwing attacks at his political
opponents or the blm movement which is
it's important that he's recognizing how
radical left
the blm movement is but he's reminding
people of history
history is the key here the
forgetfulness is the key here
the left hates history
that's why they want to rewrite history
and when they don't rewrite history they
want to erase history
and we're not they're not erasing
history books they're
desecrating and tearing down historical
statues historical figures
not even just the really bad ones you
know the ones who
sided with the confederacy or something
like that they're pulling down
george washington they're pulling down
thomas jefferson because they have a
narrative they have this narrative that
america was racist
and terrible from the beginning and it's
awful and
you no one should support it and we've
got to get away from that history and
overturn that history and
liberate ourselves from the oppressive
past then we can move forward into the
progressive future now anybody who
actually reads the founding fathers
anybody who looks into their lives will
find out that what the left is saying is
complete bs
the founding was not racist wasn't
racist at all
the institution of slavery existed
obviously that institution complicates
american history but to call the
founders and the founding racist
or bigoted or oppressive or whatever is
absurd it's not defensible if you know
the history
so what does the left do they want to
erase the history and here's what trump
does in a very
very practical way trump is so good at
this
at painting pictures at creating images
in your minds that's why
when he was talking about the the other
candidates in 2016
he would create these images so he'd
talk about you talk about how little
marco is always sweating
right you know he used to go back oh
that little marco he's always sweating
he always likes to drink water he's
always sweating
he thought why is he going after him for
perspiration well he's doing it to
create this image
of a of a young politician who's nervous
who's not confident
who maybe isn't so sure of what he's
saying
jeb bush he got low energy jeb he didn't
call him a moderate jab or squishy jab
or liberal jab no
low energy it creates such an image of
this guy who's just
he's just a little lethargic he's not
going to be able to take the fight
to washington all these kinds of images
would come up crooked hillary it's an
image of a crook
even the idea of something being crooked
it's not quite straight it's not quite
right
and that's what he's doing here he says
you remember blm he doesn't talk about
the origins of blm
at the meeting of patrice calors and
opal to medi
and alicia garza getting funded by the
open society foundation which is run by
george soros he's not talking that's
way too technical he says you remember
blm was founded they were marching down
the street
saying pigs in a blanket fry them like
bacon
because that happened we saw that video
that creates a hideous ugly image it's
an image that actually took place by the
way
when blm was founded so that's where our
mind goes
that's what we have to remind people of
we have to remind people
of not just joe biden though we should
bring up his words
and his sayings and his role in history
too but the whole history
of the left of the democratic party
because people don't remember especially
with this
24 hour forget 24 hours in our 24 minute
news cycle things are changing so
fast people forget about this kind of
thing and it's very easy then
to rewrite the past to erase the past
and move forward
into these ridiculous leftist ideologies
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you